Mit schwerem Gerät im Sondereinsatz:
Florian Domberger fährt mit seiner
Spezialtruppe
in die sogenannten „Brotwüsten“ im
Bundesland Brandenburg.
Er will die Einwohner in der wenig besiedelten
Region mit gutem Brot versorgen.
Die momentane Bäckerei-Situation
in Brandenburg ist ernst.
Also, immer mehr kleine Handwerksbetriebe,
die machen zu.
Und dadurch müssen sich die Leute
immer mehr auf die Discounter verlassen.
Und das Brot vom Discounter finde ich also
nicht besonders gut.
Und da muss man was dagegen tun.
Heute geht es nach Biesenthal.
Die Kleinstadt nördlich von Berlin hat knapp
6000 Einwohner.
Handwerklich gebackenes Brot ist trotzdem
Mangelware.
Ein Fall für das
„Brotwüstenexpeditionsfahrzeug“.
Die mobile Bäckerei wurde zuvor in der
Armee genutzt:
in der neutralen Schweiz, die eher nicht für
ihre kriegerische Art bekannt ist.
Die Schweizer hatten 168 Stück davon,
ungefähr für jedes Bataillon der Armee eines,
und wollten damit die Armee im Feld
versorgen.
Die haben das natürlich nie eingesetzt,
sondern haben immer nur damit geprobt.
Und die wurden ... Anfang der 2000er-Jahre
wurden diese ganzen
mobilen Bäckereien dekomissioniert und
verkauft.
Und ich hab eben die Nummer 130
bekommen.
Der Platz im Expeditionsfahrzeug ist optimal
ausgenutzt.
Es gibt eine Knetmaschine, einen Wassertank
und einen Gasofen –
alles andere ist Handarbeit.
Die mobile Bäckerei ist autark und könnte
auch in einer wirklichen Wüste Brot backen.
Florian Domberger sieht die Nachteile der
engen Backstube eigentlich als Vorteile.
Für die mobile Bäckerei gilt eigentlich:
Klar ist es ungünstig, dass sie eng ist,
weil weniger Platz heißt weniger Freiheit bei
der Arbeit.
Aber auf den zweiten Blick ist es eigentlich
sehr interessant, weil man gezwungen ist,
effizient und effektiv zu arbeiten. Und man
denkt anders über Handwerk nach.
Die deutsche Brotkultur ist immaterielles
Kulturerbe der UNESCO –
mehr als 3000 verschiedene Brotsorten
wandern täglich in den Ofen.
Trotzdem gibt es immer weniger Bäcker, die
noch vollständig selbst backen.
In den vergangenen 60 Jahren sank deren
Zahl von 55.000 auf knapp 11.000.
Große Ketten und Aufbackstationen füllen
diese Lücke.
Mit vorproduzierten Teigen, die künstliche
Zusätze enthalten.
In Florian Dombergers Brot kommen nur
Wasser, Mehl und Salz.
Das Geheimnis ist der Sauerteig:
Die gärenden Milchsäurebakterien und Hefen
sorgen für den Geschmack.
Das ist, würde ich mal sagen,
der ganz, ganz große Unterschied.
Dadurch gibt’s mehr Aroma, Versäuerung.
Das ist ’n ganz anderes Brot, ’n ganz anderes
Lebensmittel.
Florian Domberger hat auch eine stationäre
Bäckerei in Berlin.
Gelernter Bäcker ist er nicht.
Fast 20 Jahre lang arbeitete er als Logistiker
in Australien, der Schweiz und Asien.
Dort lernte er auch seine Frau kennen.
2015 beschlossen sie, gemeinsam eine
Bäckerei aufzumachen.
Es hat mich echt überrascht, wie sehr die
Deutschen ihr Brot lieben.
Ich dachte nur: „Wow!
Wenn wir wirklich eine Bäckerei eröffnen,
wäre das schön.
Dann könnten wir zusammenarbeiten
und anders leben.“
Früher hat er allein die Brötchen verdient.
Jetzt können wir das gemeinsam als Team
machen.
Das Brotwüstenexpeditionsfahrzeug ist ein
voller Erfolg.
Rund 70 bis 80 Tage im Jahr ist es in
Brandenburg im Einsatz,
auf Marktplätzen oder Festivals.
Auch in Biesenthal kommt der
Frische-Service gut an.
Der letzte Bäcker,
der frische, richtige Bäcker – der Bäcker
Benndorf – hat leider zugemacht,
jetzt vor mehr als einem Jahr. Das war sehr
schade.
Ansonsten gibt’s nur noch halt die
Industriebäcker in den Großmärkten.
Hier in der Region, wo es wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr so viele Bäcker gibt,
ist es ’ne gute Idee, um die Leute wieder an
frisch gebackenes Brot zu kriegen.
Ohne Konservierungsstoffe, einfach frische
Zutaten, natürliche Zutaten,
regionale Zutaten – das Beste, was man
machen kann.
Ja.
Mit jedem Einsatz in der Brotwüste
kommt Florian Domberger seinem Ziel näher:
gutes Brot für alle.